E aí
[Música]
a
vinte e oito de Fevereiro do ano de 2010
ou eu com seis anos de idade no meu
primeiro dia de aula e eu tava muito
feliz empolgada com a ideia de ir para
escola de aprender algo novo de me
comunicar de ter outros colegas né
correr pintar desenhar de um mundo
inteiro pela frente
é mais uma das primeiras lições que eu
aprendi foi que nem sempre as coisas são
como a gente gostaria que fosse e quando
eu cheguei na escola eu me deparei com
dois ambientes o de punição e o de
julgamento
primeiro punição por conta da
metodologia de ensino aonde o professor
ele tá lá na frente e ele é o detentor
de todo o conhecimento a nossa função
como aluno é decorar aquilo que o
professor disse que o correto não ao
estímulo para a gente pensar em
alternativas resoluções de problemas
forma diferente de fazer aquilo é como
se a partir daquele momento o botão do
pensamento divergente tivesse sido
desligado
os exames são baseados em apurar a
retenção de conhecimento Oi e aí eu fico
me questionando
Mas será que isso é uma ferramenta útil
nos dias de hoje aonde informação está a
um clique de distância
e eu me lembro de um episódio que
aconteceu comigo quando eu tinha recém
inventado na escola que a professora
pediu que a gente desenhasse uma árvore
e eu muito feliz empolgada fui lá e
desenhe a árvore que tava aqui na minha
imaginação
E aí a professora começou a percorrer
entre os corredores e tal avaliando os
trabalhos realizados parou diante da
minha mesa e disse que a minha árvore
tava errada Poxa tá isto Pinto árvore de
cor de rosa e azul e árvore é verde
naquele momento eu fiquei muito
decepcionada mas não decepcionada com a
professora decepcionada comigo como pôde
ou errado Como pode a minha imaginação
tá errada porque
aquele momento eu consegui a minha
imaginação ela tivesse sido retirada de
mim e colocada num cômodo Sabe aquele
cômodo da casa que a gente acaba
colocando as coisas que não usa mais ai
eu tenho um sofá antigo logo lá no
quartinho escondido coloca um lençol por
cima esqueço foi assim que eu me senti e
eu sei que isso não aconteceu só comigo
várias pessoas passaram por episódios
semelhantes e é nossa imaginação foi
colocada de lado e o segundo ambiente
que encontrei foi o de julgamento eu fui
uma criança muito gordinha eu tinha o
dente torto e filha de agricultor por
conta disso quando eu cheguei na escola
o meu nome se confunde muitas vezes com
coluna com
baleia com dentuça isso é muito
frequente e fez com que eu quisesse
esconder isolar me tornar invisível só
que eu não podia Então a maneira que eu
tinha era aonde eu podia ficar um pouco
mais invisível ficava e por conta disso
eu não comecei não aparecer mais aí eu
tinha vontade de fazer aquilo Não não
vou porque as pessoas podem me julgar eu
tinha vontade de fazer uma apresentação
não não vou porque as pessoas podem me
julgar e foi assim por um bom tempo e
por conta disso eu resolvi colocar uma
armadura bom se as pessoas me julgam
pela maneira que eu sou essas pessoas me
julgam por como a minha imaginação a tua
eu O que é melhor aluno né ao menos a
melhor aluna de sala de aula porque daí
eu sigo o padrão tira notas boas e aí eu
não vou ter um dele um dedo apontado
para mim dizendo que eu errei e foi
assim por um bom tempo até que eu
comecei a sentir um incômodo eu sentia
que tinha algo que não tava legal É como
se eu tivesse sido colocada dentro de
uma caixa pequena e aí eu fui crescendo
e a caixa continuava pequena e começou a
ficar desconfortável E aí eu comecei a
perceber poxa se não fizer nada as
coisas vão continuar assim depende de
mim agir fazer alguma coisa porque senão
eu vou viver a vida que os outros acham
que a correta para mim eu vou seguir o
padrão aquilo que todo mundo faz
e nesse incômodo eu comecei a fazer
pequenos movimentos
então quando eu tava saindo do ensino
fundamental para o médio eu queria muito
trabalhar aí eu estudava de manhã e eu
teria que isto É
mas não passava ônibus no período da
noite onde eu morava então eu pensei
Poxa como que eu vou resolver isso e aí
eu conversei com os alunos que moravam
próximo a mim e verifiquei quase deles
teriam desejo de estudar à noite fiz uma
listinha Entrei em contato com a
secretaria de educação da cidade sem
ninguém saber uma menina de 14 anos
marcando reunião Marquei uma reunião com
ela
e final conversar com ela sai um dia da
escola ninguém sabia falei com ela e no
ano seguinte estava eu trabalhando
estudando à noite
e aí eu comecei a sentir gosto por isso
poxa eu consigo fazer as coisas e aí
nesse movimento né esse é um exemplo
muito singelo de uma coisa que eu fiz
mas que eu quero deixar de mensagem que
a gente precisa agir não adianta a gente
sofre só ficar né chorando por conta das
coisas que não consegue sustentar tentar
fazer alguma coisa com a a e foi nesse
movimento que comecei a resgatar minha
confiança criativa é mas antes de falar
de criatividade eu preciso falar para
vocês de imaginação porque a imaginação
é a fonte da nossa criatividade é a
partir da Imaginação que a gente vai ter
ideias deslumbra cenários possibilidades
e todos nós somos seres imaginativos a
gente tem a possibilidade de pensar em
coisas que existem coisas que não
existem coisas que podem existir
se eu pedir para vocês imaginarem agora
um elefante cor-de-rosa aqui do meu lado
eu tenho certeza que vocês vão conseguir
me ajudar Esse é o poder da nossa
imaginação E aí eu tô na imaginação eu
dou um passo além e chego na
criatividade porque a criatividade eh
usar minha imaginação para resolver
alguma situação que eu tenho resolver um
problema como meu da escola eu queria
estudar à noite mas não tinha condições
eu achei uma só a resolver ele deu certo
e é isso a gente usar esse poder da
Imaginação junto com alguma ação
mas quando eu falo de criatividade eu
acho engraçado que muitas pessoas dizem
assim não Taíse eu não sou criativo Por
que que a atividade tem a ver com um
músico com pintor com cantor com
publicitário ou outras pessoas ousam
dizer que criatividade é dom a pessoa
nasce criativa ou esquece acabou as
possibilidades e não é isso são mitos
que foram implantados
criatividade é coisa de todo mundo Todos
nós somos seres criativos basta a gente
olhar evolução humana e a gente se
depara com centenas milhares de criações
envolvendo o poder da criatividade
ah poxa o pessoal tinha uma necessidade
foi lá o só imaginação e resolveu
descobriram fogo criar um lança criar um
armas criar uma carroça
criaram símbolos a escrita uma
infinidade é só a gente parar e refletir
tudo que tem a nossa volta quando não
existia Quem te viu quem te vê ideia de
criar o que a gente tem hoje que a gente
usa
bom então Isso é criatividade e todos
nós temos essa possibilidade
bom e quando olho para a palavra
criatividade eu gosto de fazer esse tipo
de brincadeira
distrair palavras bom olhando
criatividade eu consigo extrair outras
duas palavras
Criar e atividade
criar vende dar origem a algo e e
atividade vende ativa aquilo que se
movimenta logo criatividade é pensar e
agir se eu só tenho ideias e não faço
nada com essas idéias eu tô sendo um ser
imaginativo a partir do momento que eu
decidi implementar uma ação as minhas
ideias aí sim eu tô usando o poder da
minha criatividade
é só que é natural que o nosso cérebro
que ele é percorrer aquele caminho que
consome menos energia nosso cérebro não
quer ficar lá gastando energia à toa eu
gosto muito da analogia que eu tô lá no
mar na beira do mar caminhando molhando
os pés na água
quando eu tô lá fazendo isso eu tô
relaxando o meu corpo gastando pouco
energia né então lá tranquila a partir
do momento que eu decido nadar Mar
Adentro naquela imensidão de
possibilidades
eu tô saindo da inércia tô saindo
daquilo que é o Óbvio para todo mundo
torcendo novas possibilidades e quando
eu faço isso eu acesso novas
possibilidades eu tô usando o meu
repertório
porque todos nós temos uma caixa de
repertório essa caixa como se fosse uma
caixa elástica e a partir do momento que
eu coloco coisas dentro dela ela vai se
expandindo e o que que tem lá dentro tem
tudo que eu vi tudo que eu ouvi as
coisas que eu tive experiência o meu
conhecimento aquilo que eu li as minhas
crenças tá tudo lá dentro e aí quando eu
preciso eu vou lá acesso isso e começo a
fazer conexões
porque criatividade não é o pegar um
papel em branco e desenhar algo
totalmente do zero totalmente novo
criatividade eu consegui combinar coisas
e eu consegui me afastar do tempo e
espaço que eu tô enxergar novas
possibilidades
eh eu pegar aquilo que está desconectado
e conectar eu juntar um pedacinho de
água aqui com um pedacinho de algo lá e
transformar em algo totalmente novo Isso
é criatividade
O que é natural que é quando a gente
fala e disso né eu gosto muito de trazer
um exemplo para as pessoas entenderem do
celular e da câmera fotográfica pensa em
que antigamente o celular era um meio de
comunicação as pessoas usavam ele para
fazer ligação e aí alguém pensou porque
não combinam celular em uma câmera
fotográfica duas coisas totalmente
distintas e Oi e aí essa pessoa foi lá e
combinou isso e hoje todos nós queremos
um celular com a boa câmera para bater
foto registrar os nossos melhores
momentos
bom e quando essa pessoa foi ter essa
ideia provavelmente passou pela cabeça
dela muitas coisas
quem está errado isso as pessoas rirem
de mim esse as pessoas zombarem de mim e
se eu for um fracasso
E esses são aqueles pensamentos que
muitas vezes nos bloqueiam e acabam
deixando a gente de agir porque daí que
não ficar atormentando nossa cabeça e a
gente pensa Poxa não vou fazer eu vou
fazer porque se eu fizer pode dar errado
E é natural a gente tem que aprender a
lidar com esses meses com esses não sei
as com essa possibilidade de falhar que
quando eu falo que eu tô querendo algo
diferente eu tenho possibilidade de
falhar só que se eu for lá vou aprender
com isso
o medo do julgamento é algo também que
bloqueia muito a gente e se eu tivesse
pensando no meio do julgamento não
estaria aqui hoje
porque provavelmente nesse momento
algumas pessoas devem estar me julgando
pelo maneira que eu falo pelo que eu tô
falando pela maneira como eu tô vestida
pelo tom da minha voz a gente não
consegue controlar isso é algo externo e
por que que eu vou gastar tanta energia
com algo que externo que eu não consigo
controlar é importante que a gente
consiga seguir nesse caminho e deixar o
julgamento de lado o medo é um sinal de
alerta para gente né vamos ver se
realmente vai dar certo vamos ter uma
atenção aqui mas o julgamento que
externem precisa de controlar e a gente
precisa seguir nesse caminho porque a
criatividade ela anda junto com a
coragem são caminhos Paralelos
ao mesmo tempo que eu dou um passo na
criatividade eu tenho que dar outro na
coragem eu gosto de me imaginar como
Equilibrista eu tô lá naquela linha
assim balançando ao mesmo tempo que eu
tenho as possibilidades de errar eu
tenho a possibilidade de acertar e é eu
que tô lá eu que tô caminhando né
ninguém que vai com a minha por mim bom
E se eu errar eu vou aumentar minha
curva de aprendizado é essa mensagem que
a gente tem que deixar
E além disso as nossas ideias elas estão
uma linha tênue entre aquilo que é
genial e aquilo que é maluquice então ao
mesmo tempo que eu posso ter uma ideia
aqui que é maluca daqui um tempinho ela
já é genial Pense nas Coisas
extraordinárias que foram criadas e como
elas foram aceitas no início esse foram
aceitas é isso temos que ter coragem
para fazer essa caminhada
os sonhos eles não se realizam só porque
a gente sonha tem um caminho árduo
trabalho a ser feito para a gente
conseguir alcançar
e o mundo é feito por pessoas que
decidiram construir o mundo em que vivem
o resto das pessoas apenas sobrevive no
mundo que foi criado por essas pessoas
que têm atitude que querem criar algo
que estão usando sua criatividade
por isso eu digo para vocês hoje sonhe
Acredite dedique se realize Por que eu
sou tudo aquilo que me inspira muito
obrigada a
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí